[Music]
do you know what's the shape of a dish
satellite called
that's right a Dish satellite is
parabolic in shape we've seen this in
one of our previous videos it's made up
of this type of a curve we can find many
such examples of parabolic surfaces in
our daily lives one of them is the
mirror used in a flashlight it's also
made up of this type of a curve let's
consider just one of all these curves
such a curve is called parabola
in this video we will understand what
exactly a parabola is we can see that a
parabola
looks like a u-shaped curve but every
u-shaped curve is not a parabola a
parabolic curve has a specific property
that makes it a parabola let's begin
with understanding why the dish
satellite or the mirror in the torch is
parabolic in shape
in the case of the dish satellite due to
the parabolic shape all the incoming
signals falling on the dish are
reflected towards a single point this is
where the receiver is placed so the
parabolic shape helps in concentrating
all the incoming signals at a single
point such a point for parabola is
called its focus and every parabola has
a focus point and this is what makes a
parabola so useful for example in the
case of a torch a bulb is placed at the
focus of the parabolic mirror we know
the light emitted by the bulb spreads in
all directions but due to the parabolic
mirror the light emitted in this
direction is reflected in the forward
direction like this so we see that a
parabola is a u-shaped curve related to
which there is a special point called
its focus a focus point of a parabola is
similar to the center point of a circle
and so in the case of a circle a
parabola is actually defined using its
focus point let us see how let's take a
point in a plane and name it as point F
also let's take a straight line and name
it L now please listen carefully to what
I'm going to say next
we will now consider points which are at
an equal distance from point F and a
line L are there any such points on this
plane yes
consider this point P one it will be at
an equal distance from the point F and
the line L consider another such point P
- its distance from point F will also be
equal to its distance from the line L
another obvious point is the midpoint of
the perpendicular segment connecting
point F to the line L all such points
that satisfy this condition will lie on
this curve and such a curve is called a
parabola so how can we define a parabola
we see that a parabola is the set of all
points in a plane that are equidistant
from a fixed point F and a fixed line L
their given special names the point F is
called the focus of the parabola and
line L is called its directrix notice
that the shape and the position of the
parabola will depend on the position of
point F and line L that is depending on
the point we take as our focus and a
line which we take as the directrix we
will get different parabolas let's say
for example we increase the distance
between the focus and the directrix here
so let's take this point as the focus
and this line as the directrix
corresponding to this focus and this
directrix this will be our parabola now
say we take this horizontal line as our
directrix and this point as our focus so
what will the parabola look like here
this will be the parabola here so we see
that depending on the focus and the
directrix we get different parabolas now
consider one last thing in this parabola
let's draw a line that's passing through
the focus and is perpendicular to the
directrix notice that the part of the
parabola above the line is the mirror
image of its spot below this line that
is the parabola is symmetric about this
line this line for a parabola is called
as its axis and the point where the
parabola intersects the axis is called
its vertex
note that the distance of the vertex
from the directrix is the same as its
distance from the focus okay now can you
tell me what will be the access and the
vertex of these two parabolas for this
parabola this line will be its axis and
this point will be its vertex similarly
for this parabola this will be its axis
and this will be its vertex so in this
video we saw what a parabola is it's a
collection of all points in a plane that
are equidistant from a fixed point
called the focus and a fixed line called
directrix in the next video we will find
the equation of a parabola to stay
updated please subscribe to our Channel
[Music]
you